what's a fool
what's up boo what's up fool what's up
what's up fool that giant rock over
there man with a perm Junior get this
guest a moose our special guest Esther
ku - what a podcast yeah - in the game
ku and the game best [ __ ] title ever
next word crushes you my son why for the
party it's cool and the game Oh horrible
titles these comedy podcasts titles II I
love dark forest I think that's a
good-ass title the forest don't work for
your the park is before right oh yeah
yeah yeah it's what stuck in life in
neutral life in neutral like a special
there's no photo of you guys I was do
you know his place a middle way pity -
you're a white guy incense did another
one I'm silly boys with Sam camera silly
boy Nick yeah time with Nick and Johnny
and then sometimes on Rizzo one of
Rizal's nine podcast by the bells a good
title
[Music]
you squat your torso go squat squat
squat square because we are the littles
are we mad do we have video little
littles the most consistent podcast like
because even yeah - he started off one
for any junk - sometimes you got a
consolidated podcast what did you throw
your vodka Joey and Felicia's was my
favorite I was like one of the first
ones it was really good yeah Willy how
to write Willy yeah I might have been
chain the devil had what - he had one we
were the people that used to work with
him at a radio station they all quit
like a month they're all gone people
can't hang with podcast people different
animal right there's two legs like flat
earthers in like it's like stand-ups and
improv get out of here put some more
lotion this morning blood listen what
better than being like dry and wrinkly
though edition right or was that
moisturized we had out whatever the
lotion we had what is that that's cream
my mama I saw my makeup remover open the
other this was alcohol my beau Robert
Smith is in the house with me we're
already coffee looked up at one with
minerals in it and it has like a tint to
it no I don't want dude the Sun is as
good as it is I don't want to be sitting
there with a little piece of cancer
right the Wayans brothers yes no wasn't
like wait yeah well I was on the phone
with you at the time you were starving
another fool doesn't have his glasses on
you called me and you go cuz crap news
ladies
these are dude where are your sunscreen
I'm telling you my son has an aunt and
man dude what the first touch went to
the beach she came back Huber her scalp
bro I've seen a full back bubble up from
the beach like summers you can use a
regular sunscreen like the cheap stuff
and is really not even gonna be affected
what baby oil mom actually the water is
down with baby oil or
you could be out in the Sun to continue
and it's like dude like that's good the
shade dog like straighten the Sun did oh
my god just burning magnifying glass on
I know but you know how white people are
they like don't even put blinds in there
half of them don't they just like they
what side would you play aluminum foil
all right now tell my white people I saw
I thought about you because I saw we
said our rock we went to clean it up
we were in a valley and then we were
driving and you know it [ __ ] I saw
his heart of North there's no she no
white couple and they had a special sun
umbrella they were like they were like
lighting they were great and you well
dude chuck Bartowski walk in the Sun
Robert you should get one of those masts
bro like [ __ ] the Clippers owner's
wife one of the Asian ladies were they
driving the freeway by Monterey Park
that's selling him on his website right
now face mask they jump on charges
what's up you first heard it he's
connected what do you think what did you
think it happened you see how the
shakers isn't even Obama I think it's
connections for one
about $4,000 he did a lot of stuff of
the community before he well they're
saying that the amount of service he had
done before I guess they would have that
way they would have sentenced him with
that anyway so and community service for
what for the duis that he blamed on his
brother many of your brother did that to
you I'm not saying I'm a bad person but
if I would do something bad Boyle
Heights on suicide might get me out yeah
a little trouble right now you told
about that jaywalking ticket he was like
well that's life Downtown Crossing Los
Angeles Street when you were running
going over to local eita across the
street I dropped you off and I'm gonna
go to court and be like you don't my
eyes are so small you don't know where
my eyes were looking thanks for your
just misses case no I mean it was for a
second to look at my directions and then
he pulled me over meet your quota least
a bit of any legal term bro in Venice
where took my daughter Tuesday used to
live it was illegal right on red but the
other side was bent on this side but I
never get sick you gotta say code 46
officer and then he drop those trousers
and then you get a ticket I've been
pulled over for sometimes gotta let go
for though now one was bad out of it he
told a cop man who tell you man I will
over hit that car I made a right turn in
the hotel I'm looking at a couple at
this and I'm [ __ ] out the bond between
my legs I know I thought she was a hot
cop and you were jerking off
but we'll save you some guy on the bike
went right across in front of me in
order to not hit him it looked like I
wasn't gonna make the mistake of going
forward and like tap another car so he
can see that I was in the same lane and
that kind of got me out of it so we love
you go in the parking lot at 7-eleven on
sunset we wouldn't stay there and Jordan
or shoplifting the cop was talking to us
and the 7-eleven guy was looking at
what's going on and Joe teal was
stuffing Powerbars chair they got the
Rosato brothers over there check it out
meanwhile I got me a I'm from Chicago
ya know I'm from there I didn't start
there I started in Boston person because
there's a million Koreans here and you
just seem like more of an la Chicago
during the LA riots we had our own
Chicago Bulls like celebrations while
you guys are rioting in New York Yankees
[Laughter]
or else I would have remembered it and
in the gym we got together huh no he
looks like why though the new president
supposedly mixed with Obama man oh wow
yeah I meant why though looks like wow
see that's how good woman's imaginations
are like we could just make two guys
have sex and if we create a third like
presidential leader and we're like
different about him we see like a chick
you know what bro
she's got a hot bro she's like kind of
like some are high eggs fat cousin
romantics like that yeah yeah well see
there's a type for everybody likes
together
oh [ __ ] oh my god whoa survivor he looks
like a Hispanic Modi AG widel you guys
don't know Modi New York well anybody
who was like skinny looks like Tony
Hinchcliffe cuz he's just like bones and
saran wrap I got structure yeah keep
skinny you know but I grew up with
Mexicans Chicago Chicago like we just
when I was in first grade we had like no
Mexicans then by the time I was in
fourth grade we had like 10 and then
eighth grade we were like ton of
Mexicans you know and they develop
faster than all the other girls so I
read all the guys had crush it on like
the Mildred's and like the jessica's
before anybody else it's funny
well Mexican to 12 years old with a
mustache on no I saw them develop man
a mustache too after high school Wow
like the third year of college buddy go
to college
Wow I don't have our pin here - after
high school bro yeah but most the girl
I'm still waiting for my armpit hair
those big titties in ninth grade Robert
were 12 grazie
like I was like no we talked about I
ready bro like everybody was [ __ ]
making it and the gym except me
everybody without bushy I had nothing
bro Kojak well for 12 graders dream come
true but as coal just give a little kids
house we had a lesbian gym teacher and
she would watch us all shower
- and she would watch right she looked
like Alice from Brady Bunch
and she would hand us towels as we're
like I think you know what 8th grade
might have been the last year for
showering maybe yeah because I don't
think we only shower like once a year
when we ran the mile after shower I
always like a PE teacher was a big old
mean old Daiki looking lesbian no she
was like a ski skinny lesbian yeah which
one I'm gonna pick out of there
well the popular girls would like put
their lockers like in front of the
mirror and stare at themselves while
changing you know it was like you know
before Instagram some flowery dude
brought a compact I had no mirror bro I
know you ordering everybody [ __ ] my mom
didn't buy my brother anything I would
not even want to go shower and let's
have a flip-flop
what happenes and Joe Diaz got at least
I a bro the way con stripper
ask you for the cover charge we're gonna
go inside
you're gonna watch the girls I'm gonna
cut it in se but ever like exposed
myself to the old school dude everybody
has worked over 410 or whatever that is
exactly who is that leave no yes I'm on
the podcast Oh what happened to Adam
Murray bro what happened was the manager
at the club invited me to the straight
bar and his Latin girl she got excited
when she saw my Telemundo shirt yeah so
she took me to the back and cut to about
the ATM 80 bucks and he didn't have it
bro and he goes and I try to go to the
ATM I just could have take $80 out the
machinery to make you think that Andre
be budgeting dog so all that drama bro I
got hosed he said that I got Jackie
called as soon as like it was tight like
a minute with no [ __ ] car they said
it for the credit cards open to complete
his k2d rob a chargeback on a charge
yeah I'd be like I wasn't even there
landlord that is a sir well you read a
gentleman's club
which hotel Oh Madonn no stripclub
expecting to be ripped off you have to
usually buy them a drink if they're
gonna spend time with you and yeah it
just be I said a little Eloy with poison
in it I love I love that you know that
keeps you guys on guard on your
tippy-toes around us you don't know what
we're capable of didn't run you and I
think here oh now yeah stripper she's a
feminist hero cardi B for like drugging
those guys stupid exactly she's lucky
fatherless campaign dude and how about
guys who go to strip clubs and have like
jobs and they go spend their whole check
oh dude I knew fools like that the whole
check-box dominators
AC dudes they're strippers now that have
a wish lists like Amazon wish lists and
then like their regular customers will
buy them like an outfit this is usually
like the old man at that one strip club
I used to go exterminate at like dudes
in their 70s would go there and get like
a lap dance from their chick but they'll
give him like 100 bucks and they'll have
to put a condom on he's all the grossest
part he's all I put the condom on so
that way when he comes he comes into the
condom and not in his pants that's the
old man's going over there getting
rubbed on Robert Kraft I was distilled
it's hard food eruption I'm having sex I
saw no one said walk no sit somewhere
with wipes a box of wife that's what
I was just thinking that my head [ __ ]
lapdog I don't know it's white buffalo
sauce dude at that same Club roast there
was like a little bag tied to the wall
in that book what there was a bag nailed
to the wall by just a regular bag right
but that bag had wipies in it because
the thing is when you're exterminated in
there the lights are on you see all the
groceries
yeah rent you a Taser and at my house
who gave the place roaches Oh place was
well they go in there with their
suitcases cuz they got like ten
different outfits they put on so of
course the roaches gonna get in a
suitcase and try out a strippers house
for a week and be like I don't like this
[ __ ] house I'm going and this was like
aw like hearing this [ __ ] from a couple
of the girls they were like no they were
shameless and then let the girl that
works a front that works the register
the one that charges the people come in
and also the girls with their quotas how
many dance did you do and they all got a
kick back to the deejay and the rest of
the management in the club everybody I'd
be robbing fools everyday man that's why
they don't watch that's the problem let
me get a kickback you have to kick back
the deejay and the security that's why
they do what they do I think in part
they keep your cash and your credit
cards are just your cash person
interview tips yeah happens in
restaurant stupid if you're tipping out
the bartender tipping out the tipping
out their food runner or bus or yeah
everybody and when I was at Mesa Grill I
did took fifty percent of my tips a
little white B you [ __ ] hanging up on
the wall dog oh gotta make extra deals
in there bro oh yes
I'm also gonna play the security guard
to turn his back that too and if you're
crafty you can make more money
yeah that's what I'm just thinking like
that old guy could have just paid an
extra hundred and probably gotten real
the real thing you know yeah I think
[Music]
they should make like a dad well he used
to pipe chicks in the parking lot the
monitor I knew my mother told a story
one time they would do good
which the grocery story came back he's
getting busy already yeah he was a real
deal what they would call strawberries
[Laughter]
no matter what I mean anyway anyways
this fool I have to work with him bro
and his food was [ __ ] funny of dog oh
this will tell me that he was [ __ ]
walk around at night and like he was you
know you see a rapid by golazo miss ball
she's a rat and he [ __ ] size up his
foot he kicks it like a soccer ball so I
could fly bro but if that food was
really good at soccer dude I can imagine
him hitting a rack cuz if you're a
regular dude gonna be able to smack
around with your foot yeah jingle dome I
live in their home doctor guy he said
it's like a rap star bro
let's go her rhymes at the end this dude
and he was Teddy kid here a boy yes boy
like bumps on his forehead run his eye
whatever yeah but you got away he goes
ah gee he said that he got a haircut
from a lady and she had an infected cold
but it's funny that you say that because
I know guide you a girl and that's I do
my own feet exactly is that why you know
I could I do yoga I could paint my own
[ __ ] cousin do my toes yeah they
don't they don't all sanitize properly
so I mean you don't want to be all
paranoid yeah everywhere you go like are
they gonna wipe down the forks and the I
be paranoid after cover they should let
this bro get a staph infection like I
was but he told me he threw up because
he was smelled something and then after
that I never again with inside I'm
Alfred Robles car
the Hoke the Green whether that green
car he had it was like car you can't
sell that everything he threw it away I
remember I farted so bad one time Anna
killed these fools the Blair Witch
Project made me throw up I was born
later when that movie came out and like
oh actually you didn't make me throw up
it made everybody in the theater throw
up and I'd have to like wipe it up I
thought - just let it the Blair Witch
Project movie similar to that oh that
rock documentary GG Allin but that was
just the added footage do punch the
Rhino face
I see now and he's still singing and
then some J will talk to him - hit him -
but he [ __ ] punches the [ __ ] and he
did get stuck in knocked out and then
everybody got punched by three other
guys and then he [ __ ] it takes a [ __ ]
on stage grabs it puts it on his face oh
he was first hi everybody I was a phony
right he's a hardcore be mentors our
core core but he was first yeah they
were after him but he's old house he cut
a copy of - ha I don't think Ozzy went
even all the way he's all the way he
said he would go on stage and throat
audience and grab a 40 take a drink and
break it overs and then he just fight
everybody in the audience yeah he was
wild yeah I made old school hangover all
that stuff he made to do and hated at
first and then a second documentary was
the fish documentary and he didn't even
like fish but he followed them around
there Europe their European - started
taking acid and he couldn't deliver
anymore I don't think he ended up liking
them he just thought it was interesting
the phenomenon of everybody following
them like the dead you know so he wanted
to document that but he wasn't a fan
unemployed like fish fans they're just
hoping fish hires them anybody have you
heard from your dad John Leguizamo
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no stairs
Marcel gates road
well I don't know about trolling online
but you know she what she got death
threats and all that stuff whenever she
post something political I get trolled
yeah regular Asian they want to beat me
up yeah [ __ ] knob what we're doing
getting done with hi uh-huh no people
were talking sharing that page oh yeah
people loved those telling there was a
stone the daughter they were smoking
weed yeah the worst game yeah well we're
like super high if that's the [ __ ]
you're gonna talk she doesn't smoke
enough like I'll take it that's pretty
good pretty not that bad
yeah bigger balloons [ __ ] a wheel bro
I get it that was high at the
coach-house and people talking [ __ ] that
are really smoking weed this is wack
worst guest ever I mean look at Doug
Benson's I you guys are [ __ ] off the
roof hi but the better question is where
do you guys get your perms my hair
started curling after I let it go right
if your your hair she was never cool I
always dreamed that I'd wake up one day
I would be curly automatically like I
have to relight that's been an hour to
do I want my [ __ ] to be curly as a
little kid I just looks like ramen
before it's cooked and the page looks
like ramen so after I take a bite now
[Laughter]
to the ramen pretty impatient Jon Cryer
that's Jon Cryer you don't know Jon
Cryer you never saw the movie sequel
pretty in purple Jon Cryer I got it I
mean it's cool I start at the comedy
studio in Harvard Square in Boston how's
that that was I had a graduation class
cuz I went through a six-week comedy
class the [ __ ] bus I went to a bunch
of up for the free initiation class just
to learn Mexican scholarship yep yes I
took a class from Steve Cal ishm and he
was this Jewish comedian in Boston and
he was on Jeopardy and we were all like
oh [ __ ] Eddie Garcia yeah so my
graduation class was at the comedy
studio in Harvard Square because the
third floor of the Hong Kong restaurant
so I just think you find it all my
friends and I had like these dick jokes
and like all my friends were like so
shocked and I got I had these like jokes
about my dick when like we hung out
watching like Patriots game and I didn't
mention nothing about dicks then so well
made you mention dicks on stage if you
didn't talk about it I guess it's just
an easy go to
[Laughter]
there needs a vote on the mold some
gifted that dick samara found Jake's bro
light when they cheat on you shut up
[ __ ] you didn't [ __ ] my man [ __ ] if
they've your man had a morning dick oh
[ __ ] Bill Clinton's dick became the
topic of conversation talking about how
curved it was of everything remember
during the playing saxophone will make I
think we should all have a go fund me
for Monica Lewinsky you know lipstick I
guess it goes with the [ __ ]
yeah right Monica Lewinsky are you
joking
you really thought I had Monica Lewinsky
lipstick I never even heard of it she
should do the whole lip market she
should do lip balm lip lip exfoliater
lip injections can be a way to embrace
cold sores
you got a no yeah she's older to be
worried about losing here cuz herpes
people are too busy infecting other
people with herpes to care
so I'm tell you go in there by looking
for it and then you reaching for it and
then there's only one that worried what
a bird I love connect the word jealous I
never tried it it's supposed to work I
love taking out your web yeah brooch ear
wax gold mines white what I like yellow
you way
yeah but I'm already yellow so mine is
white yeah sometimes a bull bars in
there it just falls out you ever get it
just like when you fly your earwax
builds up for some reason it's such a
treat Oh Richard shangri-la pull made a
bomber horchata with [ __ ] flan inside
yeah for the vegan festival is there
with a few items but here I don't know
if I like that though and I love blonde
and/or chathur I love this sugary like
Bobo knows Richard Chang I just felt
like something was rotten like I'm gonna
make up Mexican boba do that tasted a
bomb-ass workshop that I had coconut
water in it anything with coconut is
amazing agents have flaky earwax type
it's true across all ages yes I don't
know I know like if anybody any Asian
will viewers who know differently I do I
found out the Asians put like hot water
in the ear and then like leak that out
is that true I guess I'm not that Asian
I know they they like just let it slip
out like they Mexican we get up we get
cold
yeah if I was smoking while doing it
I've seen it done to some Peto person
but it actually didn't work for another
[ __ ] I mom did was she got like a piece
of cotton and that's some kind of herb
and put it in my ear that's better and
olive oil olive oil and she's probably
using something to draw it out or
something then she like olive oil is the
best thing to put in there to bring
blood of eels olive oil is the best
thing to break it apart slowly all the
oxide
my house would use olive oil for
everything except cooking bro for the
earwax your stomach a newspaper rub for
cooking right now you are in my
neighborhood they used olive oil for
preyere olive oil in the Bible they
anointed everybody else get rid of that
calico cat
I like that somebody thought what time
bro and [ __ ] they wanted to get they
brought a big old tanker bro olive oil
water soldier
Genco olive oil company it was big big
Oh tink an old school gas can Frank
severe pops a cuss at each that's his
name is Jenko in the movie right yeah so
what's our lane what made you much money
I got a job on a sketch show you know I
always wanted to move to LA but I didn't
know how to buy a car so I just like put
that off I think I just stay in New York
so you never had a car no like well I
had a job where I had a company car so I
didn't really need to know how to get a
car like they just gave me a car when
somebody just gives you something you
don't know how to do it right so then I
just like move to LA recently now I know
how to get a car when did you move away
two years ago
now for two years now I know you came
out there I was I was still calling I
did and I'm I just want to say I'm so I
did last that's why I missed your
podcast the first time you go good you
booked me because I had just gotten
Sunday did you write a letter to us I
may write jokes for you what happened no
I already have a lot of like sex
material so I just did that I just had
to like narrow down what I'm gonna do
actually kind of awards you have to give
out well I didn't give out any they they
do they let the porn stars give them out
so I nominate and not nominate I
introduce the other porn stars so you
like a little bit of time and then bring
yeah yeah it was cool what kind of word
were they getting them like the best
anal best [ __ ] I think that's I think
that's like the highest award you can
get I forget it what her name is but she
wears Monica Lewinsky lipstick probably
um best group sexy best orgy they have
all kinds of categories but it's
hilarious because these girls are so
serious about it you know like they cry
thank god they're like Snoop Dogg I'd
like to thank me for all the hard work I
put it you know so be funny are you I
wasn't my dad for my left of me and I
and I met this guy Nevada took photos of
me my role then I hooked up with little
shorty in a valley no they think like
karlie cross ones and she like she has
like a hut like a porn star husband
they're like they're like the homecoming
queen and king
karlie cross I don't know that is she's
all hugest she's this beautiful girl
this porn star [ __ ] oh yeah we're being
abducted by you about Chelsea Monroe was
she there
probably not the old school chicks
anymore huh the retirees like yeah they
don't go let's go across some girl from
my high school got nominated for
something oh really
her own name Valerie I don't know like
her porn mixing up their names oh you
know but I think if you're gonna do porn
you should get like a
now like somebody's boss just walked by
they had to click on it's small for them
we'll do that guys - on the show like
guys get Awards yeah yeah they were like
straight guys getting awards and
everything
we went up post all right now yeah
you've seen between us love what I don't
know who's this big deal of Lexington I
love something lexington steele that guy
only does poor he does clean porn black
man Christian poor like we're the
lighting is real nice and it's like two
white girls and one black guy the makeup
really done high-end for high-end yeah
yeah cuz there's so much it just runs
the gamut now phones yeah you're the one
who's being weird is that my head keep
that in your head next time I saw
massage parlor said four hands yes the
fourth four hands
there's too much sauce chicks to
strangle Rob's me that's what I keep
more the idea oh those are great for
hands
feels so good to get every part of your
body man you get four hands everywhere
you walk I've never had four hands like
two people massaging you at the same
time it's like a threesome massage it
feels good in your head yeah surprises
in all the different parts of me like oh
yeah but make sure you smoke weed before
you go into the massage parlor it feels
extra nice you know don't go in there
sober that's such a waste
[Laughter]
we're still trying to figure it out all
these years later I'm looking for an old
dude who looks like Robert Kraft so we
could do an Instagram sketch uh be would
I need a fatter one Allen's Steven no
Eddie Pepitone Oh Eddie Pepitone could
do it maybe a little wig on him balding
right no the other guy from The Comedy
Store Don dumb Barris no the other fool
the old guy Argus oh yeah you need like
a chubby face to use affect somebody
manager you know cuz they say there's
video out there of it yeah I see this
Yeah right not get released I have a
video on every yeah so that's I'll
release it on my Instagram and I'll be
the messiah no other copy some bunch of
cobble to see the really laughs right oh
the couple already they're probably like
high five in accordance with your wife
to videos that's important yeah a Robert
Kraft parody you know ever since I came
F in the avians I'm like writing porn
see gotta get it out of my system they
play our first class you know Toto
regular class hotel suite
that was nice big window in Vegas yeah I
got a balcony who's nice in any of
anybody offer you do movies
well I got a I got a reply to to those
emails no I get I gave these emails
they're like I'd like to book you for a
porn scene and chuckling savatya I'm
like I don't do porn the sponsor real
smiley like when might you pointed
anywhere to keep her over there well
yeah she was afraid that this I don't
know if it was the king or somebody over
there I don't know if it was Saudi
Arabia might have been Dubai's whoever
some Romany guy over there brought her
to do comedy right but then he like he
bought her a dress like indecent like a
indecent proposal you know he bought her
a dress to like way she didn't blow him
yeah so she was she left before I was
almost at night was over before like she
did the show and I think she went back
to her hotel she called her agent she
said I have to get out of here tonight
and she flew out like in the middle of
the night or in the next morning like
she didn't want to spend the night there
at the hotel she was afraid to come on
it would have been a good gig I'm sure
Saudi Arabia they got oil he would have
paid you know was it for a year put your
tour on hold and come back and have an
amazing movie no but that pubic hair the
Saudi Arabian hair hair system going on
like there were some girls at my church
who got arranged marriage to a guy from
Jordan and I I wasn't jealous of her
like they said they assign her like
somebody to marry and he was cool with
it
I mean if you love God you gotta be cool
with it I wasn't cool with it I was like
I'm out of here
but you know sometimes you just get
assigned a Middle Eastern I'm saying
like he has a big Bush for what for she
is a grown General
was Filipino she's probably hearing too
not as hairy as yeah yeah another
penalty government no paso everybody's
hairy bro all over the comedian he was a
[ __ ] like three chicks that we write is
why do and by the by fright by a [ __ ]
Saturday night second short he'll draw
open up it show that this does anybody
here [ __ ] she's a [ __ ] bush white
chicks for these fans yeah he opened up
a stage audience members he was man just
the mayor have an ordinance I never
shaved my bush for my first boyfriend I
didn't know I just like kept it like
fluffy like his hair you know like I
didn't I didn't like take care of it or
anything and then I go then I went to my
second book when I was like oh I think
I'm supposed to like shave and nobody
tells you nobody tells you yeah if your
mom ain't a freak she to be able to tell
you yeah yeah that's my mom had a full
bush
and armpit hair so I just didn't know
[ __ ] time to shave there's seven kids
and a husband I probably wouldn't leave
her alone I have to fish with my [ __ ]
yeah I've seen people oh my god hey
Robert look at Hills night straight one
later the other day when I say Miss
Roberts
to shave I didn't know like he gave a
little ring no he never said anything I
was with him for a year to have and I
would make him eat me up every time
before we had said it's not really a
rule it's like a necessity you need that
in order to lubricate that's saying if
you don't do that if you don't go down I
mean I it's not going in because it's
not gonna be wet you're not gonna be
yeah you gotta train them we have with
us a Harrow we're grabbing the sand
dunes
it's [ __ ] rule me I just would strive
that never waited rules right yeah but
if a guy just goes there that way right
away you're like yeah it's our job to
stop them yeah you know
[Laughter]
hilarious dude yeah but these girls now
they don't like they're just balled down
there now bold man just the shell just
the [ __ ] I keep some hairs I don't want
to attract pedophiles you know like some
girls like just get rid of all of it
Johnny shades down there right Johnny
ice [ __ ] yeah I shaved by they get to a
point where you because like I used to
keep it really long like the top of my
head but now I trim it down how do you
know that I don't even shake I love you
oh man it was long I just usually look
at my face in the mirror he lost weight
man into shape unify the people shave
around it's like a landing strip
I try to be all like all cleaned up one
time I got an ingrown hair dog oh that
do happen you just just slice it open
like let the hair loose cut that [ __ ]
too much cut to my ball whatever have a
baby powder bro to cut down just to keep
your ass like not particular cancer bulk
or peanut cancer well I've known it for
years no I mean there's been there's
always been a connection between talc
and cancer we grew up with I know and
also to baby powder John also like their
baby powder and people died we had a
chalkboard in every classroom and you're
not supposed to put baby powder on
sensitive parts it's you know specially
like for girls you're not supposed to
put we could all get a huge settlement
from Johnson & Johnson well I think a
lot of actually community trying to say
that like they were never educate
about that through you know the
marketing and all that stuff and like
consumer information was kept from them
I don't know if that's true cuz I
everybody I talk to doesn't even know it
regardless of what their race or
ethnicity is but it just isn't widely
spread but when I was a kid growing up
my mom never bought powder and she never
let us use powder flour but all my
friends were using powder no we didn't
use anything nope we're not first of all
I'm not moist everywhere I don't
understand this need for powder
everybody know right I don't get it like
my brother blood like white face bro
three more in the morning
powders no good and for boys you could
get Mozart but there's a high incidence
of ovarian cancer and cervical cancer
and killing each other especially
anything that affects you when you when
you do it like as a baby you know Taketa
love she took like her mom's birth
control pills and that's how she got big
tits she like she like ate her mom's
birth control pills when she was a baby
and she said her mom is like a size a
and she's like a double D your mom your
grandmother your dad yeah that's true
yeah well that's what she believes all
the family have big titties do those a
family on my street they were from
sanella everybody had jugs a grandma
everyone's Fabro even have a
one-year-old baby he's faster he can
sing you like shrimp for kill of safety
candles and aside
I didn't want to pointed out one time
but we're at the we were just walking by
but we were at the airport the mom
didn't want to feed them cuz the area's
feeding time
so this fool wouldn't stop crying and
getting mad everything we should hand
him like a little like a device he'll
just throw it like he was just throwing
a fit I sigh God took my pizza if you
don't feed this was gonna eat us one day
I came out fat you a fat baby after cool
you know what I was so mad my my dad
thought I was like gonna grow up to be
ugly how many big families or family
five kids Wow three brothers and two
sisters a super wanted just super ya
wondering like Christian yeah
evangelical hardcore like Jesus like
Rico's family you know like Korean
missionaries like they go to freaking
Saudi Arabia they go to China and like
I'm lucky that my parents chose Chicago
huh you know like I could have been like
ended up somewhere Louisiana Delaware
well in another country in Africa or who
knows you know but yeah super religious
he's coming up and oh you know what
white people got like more point like if
you if you brought like a white person
to church you got more points than if I
brought a Mexican sorry guys knows
because I there's easier to like recruit
you know let me hit let me dumb this
fool down Oh
yeah I'll be in Arkansas November 1st
and 2nd we're at the Grove comedy club
and I'll be at the Long Beach Laugh
Factory tonight tonight Wednesday for
you libelous this week pull up here
Dallas at the Arlington improv March
29th through 31st Charlotte North
Carolina comedy zone April 4th through
the 6th Tacoma Washington April 18
through 20 in Albuquerque at the Ysleta
resort April 27 Spanish shows here we go
Riverside April 9 at live art center of
Riverside bureau chief days with Rodrigo
Torres
Johnny Rizzo - Rizzo
get tickets at the door
San Diego April 13 comedy palace in the
Gold Room fool yeah I know you have like
3 of them going on or two of them so
yeah I told MIT's up to him the whole
thing is like you know don't you know
hit him up but you know don't like I
don't want to be your telling you every
time I see a bra that's oh my god even
know the date of that show I haven't
heard anything yeah so nobody's telling
me about you know though I told myself
uh come on he said yeah but we have
we're gonna do it on our own terms and
that's it no I don't know if like oh is
he fat skinny with no legs there you go
how about we did my type he's my goal
weight how about we just donate to him
to him or something I like to know
yeah cuz I don't want to do another page
show we almost weren't able to do this
free Kevin and being April foolishness
that you're gonna be because we had an
issue with that because he's gonna do
Microsoft Theatre I think in October
like we gotta have enough time with you
know he's gonna kind of lay low a little
bit occasional Comedy Store spots here
and there I don't know about a
fundraiser thing where he's advertised
no that I don't know I'll see what's up
pulling that minute talk to me though
yeah call me though [ __ ] of you're here
dog oh I think you have the talcum part
a story so does your uh your do your
parents like freak out of what you do or
what you say I don't know the thing is
my siblings are all crazier than me so I
don't think I phased them maybe how
though how do they compete hard it's a
big [ __ ] lips I have a transgender
sister as she wants to get surgery to
like you know be a guy be a girl girl
yeah so they're like you and your dick
jokes like well you don't really face it
you don't mean like hardcore yeah yeah
yeah another Christian your brother the
transgender goes to church - no no the
kids I took the kids out of Christianity
hell yeah I took him out of the church
I'm like you guys let's get out of here
she lives she lose her life as a woman
at this point yeah yeah yeah that's like
refreshing what's up we are dates fool I
just got Texas with you that's right and
you the April as shown represent yeah
man come on yo our email or
Esther ku comm es ta TI k you calm your
handles on social media Esther ku ku
what's up fool Esther ku last night on
comedy confession party with Jack Jr oh
yeah I do his podcast that was fun
listen to that Jack Jr comedy confession
podcast Pauly Shore of the haha Club
babysitting the Jeff Garcia somebody's
gotta be there so mobile brothers what
cheek now that yes Bell's palsy
I got Bell's palsy what OH his face went